hey guys how's it going so today is very
very exciting today we were having a
home pod party but before we get into
what's going on today yesterday was
Jenna appreciation day oh very
appreciated but doesn't it carry over
until tonight it does because I don't
get to see you much yesterday so let's
cut to yesterday Jenna appreciation day
guess what's in this box guys it's a
home pod but it's not a home pod for me
it's a home pod for Jack it is a gift
today is Friday it is Jenna appreciation
day I decided to have this day in honor
of my sister Jenna because she does a
lot of stuff for me she does a lot of
stuff for all of us a lot of stuff for
all of our friends so I thought what
better way to celebrate Jenna than
getting her present we were gonna go to
dinner but we got tired so instead Jeff
and I are gonna go to dinner yeah and
then we're also going to the Apple store
because instead of getting an extra
white one I decided to get a black one
for my desk I'm sorry not black Space
Gray so I wanted it to match my new iMac
Jeff also got a home pod you like yours
yeah Maddy's also impressed with it I
don't think know where Maddie isn't this
crazy general appreciation appreciating
general I guess what the bag is
functional it was great we think Maddy
so you think you won't give Jenna some
love Oh should I said her name he knows
that paper that died honey I'll see you
soon okay
so we can be a four jaw appreciation day
yes we should look out Kenny what gentle
like I'll get hurt a bit crazy for it
there's only one out really no there's
gonna be more okay we're going in let's
count it's really hard to demo here
because it's very well
really be able to get secure
Wow well are you all been waiting if
it's perfect
thank you
we'll give you this in first this is the
warm-up gift if it's from that stores
what have been waiting for make just
have any pretzels here i walked in i was
like no this is appropriate you guys can
share it this i had to custom make this
bag because customizable okay you have
to because i taped it to the box
night I couldn't find wrapping paper but
like I have so much of it surprise can
you believe it falls on natural I had
bought one for myself and then I was
like you know what Jon's been so sweet
and so nice did you want watch my videos
that I knew is gonna be a home pod oh
she gets well because I talked to you
yesterday and I said I do you knew I
would thought you wanted you gonna buy
them I didn't but I forget what gave it
away I think I actually remember what I
did because I said something about it
coming tomorrow and I was trying to
build why do you think I asked you which
color I should get I was like which one
do you like which one do you think that
I should get remember and you're like
well which one do you like watch my
video I spent a lot as I wanted it
okay we need to see the cake so could
you hold this I am actually very shocked
because I basically told them this last
minute and they did a really good job
this is the home pot - yeah it was a lot
taller when it was in the car but I hit
a mugger speed box
well I needed to get a big enough so
that people could know did you get the
pic good dimensions okay III will say
like the perforation stuff is pretty
cool oh these are staples watch out this
is you can't eat it
don't don't eat it sorry to see max
League of Legends match now huh no
thieves is play and they are what's
their score do you know the record is
yeah they're two weeks yeah I guess
you're right for it - I'm gonna get
great I'm taking my shirt off in there
in together I drew these brothers
perfect timing get out of here
Wow well that didn't go very well but we
got a cookie we're heading back now to
the party so I will tell you ma'am
League of Legends they know how to party
with the cookies this is definitely
gonna be turning into a dog party I
think there's like five dogs that are
coming and the whole theme of the party
is the whole pot and I haven't even
opened it yet so I'm gonna open it up
right now this is the whole theme of the
party and it isn't even open yet oh this
is the only reason I'm here I wasn't
sure but sighs it's gonna be it's it's
perfect the size it is is perfect yeah
with this total it's smaller than I
thought it's better than I thought now
it's like I thought I was gonna be like
this much taller
it makes music it's kind of like the
life but not what house you can talk to
it yes
what do you say to it you can say
whatever you want me a good song I'm
trying to look at the home fire you sure
media phone I seen a whole now playing
the 80s radio hey Siri turn the volume
all the way up
first of all you down who Rosie Encino
Rosanna pansino is an American actress
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you know there's an accelerometer in
this yes okay so Matt was like so what's
the whole pod to it like did you know
much my video I'm like guys hello what
do you think everything spending my last
week dedicated to making videos about
the home box could you help me one
variation you want a super tiny
itty-bitty crumb very small crew it's so
smooth that I tried to give us she
caught us I caught them thank you for
the pizza Alex Alex up and brought us
pizza so good you've been busy doing a
lot of things yes I'm working on a
secret project right no no
so I haven't got to see your face and I
know but now I hanging out but I want to
show her at the home pod cake to make
sure that we have the approval of RO
right
I approve you even got the texture
around the Sun yeah that's cuz I like
what I can do what we can fix this we
can fix this it's fine
everything's gonna be totally fine this
is almost identical so as you guys can
see here this is my home pod cake and
this is the home pod you can see some
slight similarities as far as the color
[Music]
[Applause]
so I tried to write your name on it
six years old there's no more milestones
and for like 65 it says that's it that
is true except today I'm gonna eat my
slice of pizza my cookies
swedish fish then I have a dinner after
this it's over calorie-wise take one to
go so good
[Music]
my friends artyom garden he's actually
good boy yeah oh my god you have some
skills he does what do you think you
prove I do I'm good you like this track
one of them over here found the DJ good
boy come on stop good boy yes you're an
angel I love it he's incredible
you think you know he's gonna make it to
top hundred this year how about that
Mario Kart tournament that we had listen
okay
it was rigged a little bit I don't know
why I didn't win I should have won I'm
calling shenanigans Alex I'm calling
Alex out nothing you know what I have
yet to meet anybody on the street so I
still have my hundred I'm not playing
though you haven't yet Juicy's vlogging
but I have to vlog too as a mic on the
end the mics on it I see if mike is
primarily on I would like to say well
Matt just rode my blog Oh No
my vlog is over
this is RT boy featuring Emma Louise
that's boy I like this okay got it
this is happening huge pieces like a
huge picture here's a personalized
station of Lindsey Stirling
yeah I'm samba you would be like which
one first
you